does apple's unified memory absolutely  destroy its windows competition both  these machines right here have 16 gigs  of memory but the surface laptop studio  also has a dedicated rtx graphics card  that's four gigs of its own ram i went  ahead and opened five tabs in the  default browser and then i loaded up  another five tabs in chrome and open up  photoshop and open up ten raw images and  now i'm launching adobe lightroom  classic let's do an ultimate test start  this render in davinci resolve and then  we're going to jump into lightroom i'm  going to go and select all of these  photos let's see how these things  perform while we're maxing out the  graphics and the cpu let's open up our  youtube video  look at that right there instant on the  mac unified memory on apple's m1 systems  the m1 pro especially absolutely  destroys windows 11 with 16 gigs of  memory